in der brandenburgischen Gemeinde
Zeuthen wird seit knapp fünf Jahren
dieser Fußgängertunnel erneuert weil die
Deutsche Bahn das Ding nicht fertig
bekommt ist das Ortszentrum seit 2018 in
zwei Teile geteilt die Anwohner und die
Gewerbetreibenden leiden in Zeuthen
haben sie die Faxen dicke das kenne zu
ja nicht vernünftig man muss ständig
rumlaufen wenn man rüber will auf der
anderen Seite also wir sehen das hier in
der Straße ganz viele Leute sich
beschweren und traurig sind weil die
Umsätze eingebrochen sind aufgrund
dieser Situation Läden haben geschlossen
aber ändern können wir sowieso nicht
also wir warten und warten und warten
und warten es ist einfach nicht
nachvollziehbar dass dieser Ort jetzt
schon fünf Jahre wegen einer relativ
kleinen Baustelle
auseinandergerissen ist die Bahnstrecke
verläuft ins Zeuthen mitten durchs
Ortszentrum deshalb hoffen hier alle
dass der notwendige Neubau des Fußgänger
Tunnels schnell und reibungslos verläuft
doch bald nach Beginn der Bauarbeiten
treten Risse diesem historischen Gebäude
auf dann kommt es laut Bahn zu Problemen
mit dem Baugrund Grundwasser trinkt in
die Baugrube ein immer wieder muss der
Eröffnungstermin verschoben werden in
Zeuthener Rathaus hat man den Glauben an
die Deutsche Bahn längst verloren wir
befinden uns seit 2018 im Würgegriff der
Deutschen Bahn der ganze Ort leidet
runter die Ortsentwicklung leidet runter
die Gewerbetreibenden leiden drunter die
Eigentümer hier die Anlieger es die Bahn
ist kein verlässlicher Partner für die
Gemeinde Zeuthen die Kunden kommen nicht
von einer Seite auf die andere und die
Ladenbesitzer kämpfen seit einem halben
jahrzehn Sperrung ums wirtschaftliche
Überleben
es ist einfach die ganze Laufkundschaft
nicht mehr da die fehlt diese Richtung
kommt keiner weil ist hier ist alles zu
und kommt keiner natürlich ja bei der
Deutschen Bahn versucht man das Bau
Desaster gar nicht erst schön zu reden
schriftlich heißt es man habe
Verständnis dafür dass die wiederholten
Verschiebungen der Inbetriebnahme ein
großes Ärgernis sind leider waren die
genannten Umstände nicht abzusehen
das Verständnis für die Bahn hält sich
in Zeuthen in ganz engen Grenzen
ja aber man wundert sich warum solche
doch eigentlich kleineren Projekte nicht
doch ein bisschen schneller vorangehen
es ist eine Katastrophe also ich möchte
persönliche kein Gewerbetreibender sein
um damit hier mein Lebensunterhalt zu
verdienen es ist also ich finde es
jedenfalls ganz ganz furchtbar aktuell
müssen die Baupläne der Bahn noch mal
überarbeitet werden wann der Tunnel
endlich eröffnet wird kann uns derzeit
niemand sagen